اكد وزير الخارجيه الفرنسي والبريطاني في
بيان من باريس على دعم اوكرانيا سياسيا
وعسكريه واقتصاديا كما شدد على الحاجه
للحد من ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه في اطار
مجموعه السبع والضمان امن الامدادات
البيان المشترك بما سماه دعم طهران للحرب
الروسيه دي في اوكرانيا خصوصا الطائرات
الايرانيه بدون طياره
ايضا بانشطه ايران
منعها من حيازه اسلحه النوويه وفقا للبيان
المشترك
هذا هو قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان اتهام الطاهران
بارسال السلاح الى روسيا لاستخدامه في
الحرب باوكرانيا لاساس له واضافه في
تغريده على تويتر ان طرح هذا الاتهام
يوميا يهدف لاطفاء الشرعيه على تصوير
الغرب للسلاح يوميا الى اوكرانيا وقال
كنعاني ان ماي يوجهون التهمه الى ايران هم
سبب اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وهم سبب
استمرارها مشددا على طهران تعرض الحرب
وتؤيد وقفه اطلاق النار واحلال السلام
باوكرانيا